your character in the fermion he says
that his guiding star is portable
property doesn't he so there are lot in
the film I don't ring what your guiding
stars been both in life and in your
acting career as well follow my own true
nature whatever that is and I don't know
what that is a lot of time but I try to
try to dress myself attempt to trust
myself as much as possible you know in
my work and animal life when you stop
beat myself up quite so much is you know
as I can better hello in the video yeah
all the talented jocks yeah it's nice
right you got a very talented cast a
great British cars and if I'm haven't
you tell me about working with those
guys because its stellar isn't it yeah I
was fantastic I mean most most of my
work is with Robbie and Jeremy Irvine
you play spit and the you know there's
really Jeremy she's a lovely young man
you know it's really the talk is a total
sweetheart and Robbie is as such an
extraordinary career during career and
I've I've always enjoyed in what he does
and you know growing growing up as a kid
in Scotland and what watchin watchin has
worked there was nobody like him and
he's consistently got it's always a
great integrity I think with his
characters and how you push and Jeff
across you know I'm yeah so I was a dog
treat go get to work with all the best
people you know what's not to like what
kind of locks as they say in the film a
lot did you have on sets and well mostly
mostly just getting getting to be an
audience to really call team you know
he can start with good stories he's just
full of them that he's and jokes and
he's just overflowing with I'm so like
you know I just got to basically talk it
out next up and like I split my sides
when I daily basis and I'm saying yeah
what what's next year in a couple of
films coming out one is Jack the giant
slayer which is bryan singer's new movie
coming out in the spring another one
I've just been doing recently is really
exciting called snowpiercer by June bong
bong joon-ho bong korean director who
dug the mother and also the host and as
a really exciting film with Tilda
Swinton ed Harris Chris Evans Octavia
Spencer and Jamie Bell and really great
cast and really exciting futuristic film
set on a train in an ice age the last
people alive on our and it's about an
attentive social revolution on this
train and it's really like I never I'm
not seen anything like I'm really
looking forward to
you